you get to the civil authority in
Seattle in Washington you get to
governor jay Inslee who you probably
forgot ran for president I kind of
forgot that but there is jay Inslee was
asked what's going on in this freaking
autonomous zone you know are we some
two-bit Banana Republic in sleaze
response puts his head in the sand and
says I don't know nothing about it well
that's news to me so I'll have to
reserve any comment about it I have not
I have not heard anything about that
from any credible source not that you're
not credible it's just like before I
spouse an opinion I should know of which
I speak what you're saying terrorists
took over one of the most important city
in our state you know I just don't know
and you're saying that's the main news
story and it's the only thing that's
being reported in Washington I can get
slow it's just so funny because I guess
I haven't seen the news please please
please don't ask me about that cuz I
don't have an answer he doesn't have an
answer and he's he's not doing a very
effective job of lying about it either
because he doesn't have an answer he's
got to lie about it because he doesn't
have an answer because in his rhetoric
in his ideology he's supporting these
wackos and he's seeing in real time the
effects of that he's same one it's gonna
take power away from him but two it
doesn't look like it does in the in the
picture books okay it doesn't look like
it does in the leftist daydreams of this
utopian vision because so long as human
nature is broken you're not going to get
that utopia on earth and any singer
played out in real time and it's it's
left his ideology exposed as bankrupt so
there's a follow-up question on this
they say well what about these takeovers
of the streets even hypothetically
speaking here's a hypothetical answer
take over a street in Seattle where
there barricading keeping people out the
protesters are would you you know that's
a hypothetical look it we've got to have
safety I'm sure that people will find a
way to have Public Safety everywhere in
the state I'm confident of that the the
National Guard is demobilizing over two
thirds of more demobilize of yesterday I
don't know if they're completely debo
liest at this point or not but if not
that'll be shortly I believe so you see
what the reporter has to do because jay
Inslee is not playing on the level here
is he's got to pretend like it's
hypothetical say okay so hypothetically
if a bunch of Communists and anarchists
took over an entire neighborhood of
Seattle what would you do you're not
giving us an answer on what you're going
to do because it is happening so what
about hypothetically and then Inslee
says well you know look that's
hypothetical he then doesn't answer the
question and then the best he's got is
weirdy mobilizing the National Guard the
best he's got is we're going to use less
police force we're going to use less
force on the streets to stop this cuz
he's like a roba
he's like a non-playing character in a
video game right he's only got one mode
and the mode is leftism at least in his
rhetoric so he says well the only thing
I can possibly say about the police is
we're gonna take away their power even
though guess what right now I think the
people in Seattle probably want a little
bit more police power on the streets I
think even if there's SuperDuper
left-wing they're looking around and
saying I don't want warlords running
around and controlling my neighborhoods
so maybe give us a little more police
power but Inslee a prisoner of his own
ideology can't can't compute that and so
even in the hypothetical which is really
happening he can't give that answer
[Music]
[Music]